just over a year ago for the third time
in my life I ceased to exist I was
having a small operation my brains
filling with anaesthetic I remember a
sense of detachment and falling apart
and a coldness and then I was back
drowsy and disoriented but but
definitely there
now when you wake from a deep sleep you
might feel confused about the time or
anxious about over sleeping but there's
always a basic sense of time having
passed the continuity between then and
now and coming well from anesthesia is
very different I could have been under
for five minutes five hours five years
or even fifty years I simply wasn't
there as total oblivion anesthesia it's
a modern kind of magic it turns people
into objects and then we hope that again
into people and in this process is one
of the greatest remaining mysteries in
science and philosophy how does
consciousness happen somehow within each
of our brains the combined activity of
many billions of neurons each one a tiny
biological machine is generating a
conscious experience and not just any
conscious experience your conscious
experience right here and right now how
does this happen
well answering this question is so
important because consciousness for each
of us is all there is without it there's
no world there's no self there's nothing
at all
and when we suffer we suffer consciously
whether it's through mental illness or
pain and if we can experience Julian's
suffering what about other animals might
they be conscious to do they also have a
sense of self and as computers get
faster and smarter maybe they'll come a
point maybe not too far away when my
iPhone develops a sense of its own
existence now I actually think the
prospects for a conscious AI are pretty
remote and I think this because my
research is telling me that
consciousness has left the view with
pure intelligence and more to do with
our nature as living and breathing
organisms consciousness and intelligence
are very different things you don't have
to be smart to suffer
but you probably do have to be alive and
the story I'm going to tell you are
conscious experiences of the world
around us and of ourselves within it are
kinds of control hallucinations that
happen with through and because of our
living bodies now you might have heard
that we know nothing about how the brain
and body give rise to consciousness some
people even say it's beyond the reach of
science all together but in fact the
last 25 years have seen an explosion of
scientific work in this area if you come
to my lab at the University of Sussex
you'll find scientists from all
different disciplines and sometimes even
philosophers all of us together trying
to understand how consciousness happened
and what happens when it goes wrong and
the strategy is very simple I'd like you
to think about consciousness in the way
that we've come to think about life now
one time people thought the property of
being alive could not be explained by
physics and chemistry that life had to
be more than just mechanism but people
no longer think that as biologists got
on with the job of explaining the
properties of living systems in terms of
physics and chemistry things like
metabolism reproduction and homeostasis
the basic mystery of what life is
started to fade away and people didn't
propose any more magical solutions like
a force of life or an L on detail so as
with life so with consciousness once we
start explaining its properties in terms
of things happening inside brains and
bodies the apparently insoluble mystery
of what consciousness is should start to
fade away at least that's that's the
plan so let's get started what are the
properties of consciousness watch is a
science of consciousness trying to
explain well for today I just like to
think of consciousness in two different
ways there are experiences of the world
around us full of sights sounds and
smells
that's multi-sensory panoramic 3d fully
immersive in a movie and then there's
conscious self the specific experience
of being you or being me the lead
character in this in a movie and
probably the aspects of consciousness we
all cling to most tightly let's start
with experiences of the world around us
and with the important idea of the brain
as a predict
engine now imagine being a brain you're
locked inside a bony skull trying to
figure what's out there in the world
there's no light inside the skull
there's no sound either all you've got
to go on extremes of electrical impulses
which are only indirectly related to
things in the world whatever they may be
so perceptions figuring out what there
has to be a process of informed
guesswork in which the brain combines
these sensory signals with its prior
expectations or beliefs about the way
the world is to form its best guess of
what causes those signals the brain
doesn't hear sound or see lights what we
perceive is its best guess of what's out
there in the world let me give you a
couple of examples of all this now you
might have seen this illusion before but
I'd like you to think about it in a new
way if you look at those two patches a
and B they should look to you to be very
different shades of gray right but they
are in fact exactly the same shade and I
can illustrate this if I put up a second
version of the image here and join it
during the two patches with a gray
colored bar and you can see there's no
difference it's exactly the same shade
of gray if you still don't believe me
I'll bring the bar across and join them
up it's a single colored block of grey
there's no difference at all so this
isn't any kind of magic trick where it's
the same shade of gray but take it away
again and it looks different so what's
happening here is that the brain is
using its prior expectations built
deeply into the circuits of the visual
cortex that a cast shadow gives the
appearance of the surface so that we see
be as lighter than it really is
here's one more example which shows just
how quickly the brain can use new
predictions to change what we
consciously experience have a listen to
this sounded strange right have a listen
again and see if you can get anything
still strange now listen to this I think
breath is a really terrible idea
which ID and you heard some words there
right now listen to the first sound
again it's going to replay
yeah so you can now hear words that once
more for luck okay so what's going on
here is is the remarkable thing is the
sensory information coming into the
brain hasn't changed at all all this
change is your brains best guess of the
causes of that sensory information and
that changes what you consciously hear
now all this puts the brain basis of
perception in a bit of a different light
instead of perception depending largely
on signals coming into the brain from
the outside world
it depends as much if not more on
perceptual predictions flowing in the
opposite direction
we don't just passively perceive the
world we actively generated the world we
experience comes as much if not more
from the inside out as from the outside
in let me give you one more example of
perception as this active constructive
process in this in here we've combined
immersive virtual reality with image
processing to simulate the effects of
overly strong perceptual predictions on
experience in this panoramic video we've
transformed the world which is in this
case Sussex campus into a psychedelic
playground we've processed the footage
using an algorithm based on Google's
detering to simulate the effects of
overly strong perceptual predictions in
this case to see Doc's and you can see
this is a very strange thing when
perceptual predictions are too strong as
they are here the result looks very much
like the kinds of hallucinations people
might report in altered states or
perhaps even in psychosis now think
about this for a minute if it's
hallucination is a kind of uncontrolled
perception then perception right here
and right now is also a kind of
hallucination but a control to loosen
ation in which the brain's predictions
are being reined in by sensory
informations in the world in fact we're
all hallucinating all the time including
right now it's just that when we agree
about our hallucinations we call that
reality
now I'm going to tell you that your
experience of being yourself the
specific experience of being you is also
a controlled hallucination generated by
the brain now this seems a very strange
idea right yes visual illusions might
deceive my eyes but how could I be
deceived about what it means to be me
for most of us the experience of being a
person is so familiar so unified and so
continuous that it's difficult not to
take it for granted but we shouldn't
take it for granted there are in fact
many different ways we experience being
yourself there's the experience of
having a body and of being a body there
are experiences with perceiving the
worlds from a first-person point of view
there are experiences of intending to do
things and of being the cause of things
that happen in the world and there are
experiences of being a continuous and
distinctive person over time built from
a rich set of memories and social
interactions now many experiments show
and psychiatrists neurologists know very
well at these different ways in which we
experience being yourself can all come
apart what this means is the basic
background experience of being a unified
self as a rather fragile construction of
the brain of another experience which
just like all others requires
explanation so let's return to the
bodily self how does the brain generate
the experience of being a body and of
having a body or just the same
principles apply the brain makes its
best guess about what is and what is not
part of its body and there's a beautiful
experiment in neuroscience to illustrate
this and unlike most neuroscience
experiments this is one you can do at
home all you need is one of these and a
couple of paintbrushes now in the rubber
hand illusion a person's real hand is
hidden from view and that fake rubber
hand is placed in front of them then
both hands are simultaneously strokes
with a paintbrush while the person
stares at the fake hand now for most
people after a while this leads to the
very uncanny sensation that they can is
in fact part of their body and the idea
is that the congruence between seeing
touch and feeling touch on an object
that looks like a hand and is roughly
where a hand should be is enough
evidence for the brain to make its best
guess that the fake
and is in fact part of the body
you can measure all kinds of clever
things right you can measure skin
conductance and spout or responses but
there's no need it's clear the guy in
blue has assimilated the fake ad now
this means that even experiences of what
our body is is a kind of best guessing a
kind of controlled hallucination by the
brain now there's one more thing we
don't just experience our bodies as
objects in the worlds from the outside
we also experience them from within we
all experience a sense of being a body
from the inside and sensory signals
coming from the inside of the body are
continually telling the brain about the
state of the internal organs how that
heart is doing what blood pressure is
like lots of things and this kind of
perception which we call interoception
it's rather overlooked but it's
critically important because perception
and regulation of the internal state of
the body well that's what keeps us alive
here's another version of the rubber
hand illusion this is from our lab at
Sussex and here people see a virtual
reality version of their hand which
flashes red and back either in time or
out of time with their heartbeat and
when it's flashing in time with their
heartbeat people have a stronger sense
that it's in fact part of their body so
experiences of having a body are deeply
grounded in perceiving our bodies from
within there's one last thing I want to
draw your attention to which is that
experiences of the body from the inside
are very different from experiences of
the world around us when I look around
me the world seems full of objects
tables chairs rubber hands people you
lot even my own body in the world I can
perceive it as an object from the
outside but my experiences of the bodies
from within they're not like that at all
I don't perceive my kidneys here my
liver here my spleen I don't know where
my spleen is but somewhere I don't
receive my insides as objects in fact I
don't experience them much at all unless
they go wrong and this is important I
think perception of the internal state
of the body isn't about figuring out
what's there it's about control and
regulation keeping of physiological
variables within the tight bounds of the
possible with survival when the brain
uses predictions to figure out what's
there we can see objects is the causes
of sensations when the brain uses
predictions to control and regulate
things we experience how well or how
badly that control is going so our most
basic experiences of being a cell for
being an embodied organism are deeply
grounded in the biological mechanisms
that keep us alive and when we follow
this idea all the way through we can
start to see that all of our conscious
experiences since they all depend on the
same mechanisms of the predictive
perception all stem from this basic
drive to stay alive we experience the
world and ourselves with through and
because of our living bodies let me
bring things together step by step what
we consciously feed depends on the
brains best guess of what's out there
our experience world comes from the
inside out not just the outside in the
rubber hand illusion shows that this
applies through our experiences of what
is and what is not our body and these
self related predictions depend
critically on sensory signals coming
from deep inside the body and finally
experiences of being an embodied self
are more about control and regulation
than figuring out what's there so our
experiences of the world around us and
ourselves within it well they're kinds
of control hallucinations there have
been shaped over millions of years of
evolution to keep us alive in world's
full of danger and opportunity we
predict ourselves into existence now I
leave you with three implications of all
this first just as we can mr. sieve the
world we can miss receive ourselves when
the mechanisms of prediction go wrong
understanding this opens many new
opportunities in psychiatry and
neurology because we can finally get at
the mechanisms rather than just treating
the symptoms and conditions like
depression and schizophrenia second what
it means to be me cannot be reduced to
or uploaded to a software program
running on a robot however smart or
sophisticated we are biological
flesh-and-blood animals whose conscious
experiences are shaped at all levels by
the biological mechanisms that keep our
alive just making computers smarter is
not going to make them sentient finally
our own individual inner universe our
way of being conscious is just one
possible way of being conscious and even
human consciousness generally it's just
a tiny region in a vast space of
possible consciousnesses our individual
cells and worlds are unique to each of
us but they've all grounded in
biological mechanisms shared with many
other living creatures now these are
fundamental changes in how we understand
ourselves but I think they should be
celebrated because as so often in
science from Copernicus we're not at the
center of the universe to Darwin we're
related to all other creatures to the
present day with a greater sense of
understanding comes a greater sense of
wonder and a greater realization that we
are part of and not a part from the rest
of nature and when the end of
consciousness comes there's nothing to
be afraid of nothing at all thank you
then